something I was thinking about the other
day that I hadn't actually considered
for quite a while was how much in the
first half of my life I enjoyed the
activity of running and I you know I did
it quite a bit for exercise but also
just for fun sometimes as a way to get
around sometimes as part of my job
duties like when I was in the Army and I
kind of took it for granted until the
point where I couldn't do that anymore
and you know that that happened
definitively
in my early 40s when I had this terrible
accident out at Montauk and two of my
ligaments in my left knee were torn the
ACL and the MCL
never did get them replaced and
um you know the doctor basically said
well any running days that you had are
long over and at that time I was in so
much pain and there was so much rehab
involved with that that I didn't worry
about it but even in like my late 20s in
part because of you know how my bones
had shifted my ankles over pronate and
issues with that when I would run for
exercise I would find I would get
extraordinarily sore and different
muscles so I just didn't do it I you
know biked at that time and took long
walks oftentimes with a big backpack
filled with weights but I wasn't a
runner but in the early years of my life
basically from you know being a little
kid onward it was just part of how we
would uh get around and what you did in
for example gym class and it was tied in
with so many other activities and so I
thought I would you know do a Sadler
story is telling you about some of the
periods of my life and ways in which I I
got involved in running and I'll add
I'll add this as well that my my dad was
not a runner but he died by the time
that I was about to turn 12
and my mom I think if I remember right
by then had already started to take up
running
and she wound up having a boyfriend
later on several years later after my
dad died who also was a big Runner and
also a big biker he was very into
exercise you may have heard me talk
about him in another video his name was
Francis and uh he was sort of he became
sort of a surrogate dad to me and my
sister anyway coming back to things so
from you know childhood onward I
remember
engaging in a lot of games and uh you
know
things on the playground and
um during gym class where everybody
would run and some people were better at
it and some people were worse at it but
it was just taken for granted that you
were gonna run and unless you had some
sort of really outstanding physical
issue you weren't getting out of it
either
and a lot of the games you know there
was tag on the playground you run around
Chase each other we'd pretend sometimes
also to be
um battles doing Battlestar Galactica or
Star Wars battles and we'd pretend that
we were uh Fighters and Chase each other
around and make pew pew noises at each
other and then there was
um you know games like fish and whales
or Red Rover and after you got done with
school there was also you know in in one
part of the year I played for the whales
dragons soccer and actually when I went
to middle school soccer was taken very
very seriously and I uh uh you know
everybody had to be on the team so he
did a lot of running with that you know
especially if you were a half back
um
and so it was just part of
physical development and we also because
of where we lived you know and I've
talked about this in other videos as
well that I'll post to below
we had this massive
semi-natural you know partly
humanized playground of hundreds and
hundreds of Acres of woods and hills and
Meadows and marshes and you know in
order to get around we would sometimes
walk and sometimes we'd ride our bikes
but a lot of times we would just kind of
like jog from place to place because it
was a quicker way of getting around and
it was kind of fun that that feeling of
Freedom that comes with Crossing
territory quickly eating up the the
yards or miles you know and going
through these these cool Trails all over
the place so that's that's something
that we did as kids a lot in in my
neighborhood as it was slowly filling in
and we'd range sometimes for for quite a
long way and of course you'd get sweaty
and you'd get winded and you know
sometimes you get A Stitch in your side
but you just you just went on you know
it's not not that big of a deal so
we were all pretty pretty skinny and you
know ravenously eating and in pretty
good shape physically as kids me and a
lot of the other kids that I knew and we
would also play games that involved a
lot of running like we would you know
get together and we'd play basketball or
soccer or football or baseball and every
one of them involved some sort of
sprinting at least right back and forth
and chasing people and then when when we
would get together for uh various Club
things like Cub Scouts or sometimes it'd
just be like neighborhood stuff we'd all
play these games that would involve
running around like I mentioned tag but
we had ghost in the graveyard or
sardines these are kids games that that
you play in the Midwest and perhaps
other places that often involve like
going around a yard and a house and then
you know when you see the ghost in the
graveyard who's gonna try to tag you
everybody has to run to try to get to
the safe place the ghoul so run running
was was incredibly tied in with our life
and then you know when I got to middle
school I mentioned you know we all had
to play soccer and we did other you know
for for gym class we did other things in
the um
other Seasons you know we would play in
the winter we'd play indoor soccer we
also tended to play flag football which
of course involved running in the spring
there would be
um
baseball and I'm trying to think of what
else we did
um so you know and you'd always warm up
the coach would be like go run some laps
you know and then everyone would run
until you know it was it was time to
start so we just kind of took it for
granted is that that's what people do
and
when I was at University Lake School for
middle school they had an enormous
campus and at lunchtime
lunch and something like recess were
combined together so they would you know
you'd eat in a cafeteria and then you'd
basically be on your own to do whatever
the hell you wanted so long as you
showed up at class later on and I would
actually sometimes with another guy who
is also interested in doing this I would
run the trails I would actually like put
my gym clothes on after eating and go
run and uh it was it was you know
you get to know some of the trails
sometimes you'd be surprised but it was
it was fun it was uh being out in nature
and then it was you know kind of kind of
nice uh just to like see the sights and
smell the you know fresh mode hay or uh
things like that and so you know that
that was a significant part of my uh
time there and then
um you know when I got to high school
um I should have actually gone out for
cross country because I did enjoy
running in the woods and uh doing these
longer things right but we were in such
chaos in my family I was I also should
have tried out for soccer because I was
really into that but things were such a
mess after my dad died
um that that just wasn't on our Horizon
you know
um so I I didn't get in on that but in
gym class I ran we started out with a
track and field unit and I uh turned out
I had a talent for for running and so uh
our coach who was also my gym teacher
Chuck Bova you may have heard me talk
about him at other places he was like
you should go out for for track and I
was already doing uh in the fall in the
winter fencing which I loved because you
know handling swords and I got to start
doing saber and hanging out with a what
I consider to be the cool kids the
burnouts and we had a lot of fun and
then spring was for track so
I love track and I also hated track and
I I didn't like here's what I didn't
like about track eventually I got
pigeonholed in doing the what's really
the worst race that you can do in
competitive track and field which is the
400 meter and then of course you'd have
to also do because we had a small team
the mile relay where you've got four
people doing the 400 meters so the 400
meter is one lap around a track and
the reason why I say it's no fun and it
sucks is because you start out at a
Sprint and you can't really Sprint for
400 meters effectively unless you're a
super person right and so you run and
you take off and everybody's running
together in this big horde and then you
get around the bend and you start
getting a little bit tired and winded
and your muscles start to hurt and by
the time that you are at the roughly
three-quarter mark
lactic acid is built up in your body for
at least you know 10 to 15 seconds they
call it the bear because it feels like
somebody is scratching down your back
through the muscles everything's burning
you can't get enough air but you can't
stop running right even though you're
not sprinting anymore you're power
striding and actually just trying to get
the damn race over with and and
everybody else is in the same boat uh
and if you're doing the mile relay
you've also got this baton in your hand
that you're running with and you're
gonna either hand it off to somebody or
you're the last person in the link and
then you better do a good job on on that
so I wasn't so so happy with that I did
get to run the 200 every once in a while
what I really wanted to run was the 800
because I was a good distance Runner but
our coach once he decided what you were
gonna do and he decided it basically on
body type
um he was like you're a 400 Runner and I
was like well okay you know that that's
that
um and you know I would also run around
my neighborhood and me and my buddies
would get together and we'd run and it
was you know part of exercise and of
course in gym class which we had
um really throughout all of high school
you would start out most days by running
some laps just to to warm up so I you
know again I kind of took it for granted
um did my first 10 mile run on 100
degree day with a friend of mine around
Waukesha uh just to figure out that I
could actually do it and then you know I
continued running as a form of exercise
while I was studying martial arts and
working as a grill cook until I went
into the army and then of course in the
Army you run a lot it's one of the main
forms of exercise you also walk a lot
March a lot especially in basic training
but you would just you know it was quite
common that we would get up in the
morning uh
show up in formation at 6 30 for PT and
then you know sometimes it would be
calisthenics sometimes it would be other
sorts of exercise but a lot of times
they'd just be like all right we're
doing another five mile run and we'd get
together as a platoon and we we would
run basically in formation and I'll tell
you something that's kind of funny about
this I've mentioned this in my my video
that I when I talked about smoking so us
younger guys in the Army a lot of people
back then in the 1980s and 1990s smoked
Smoked Cigarettes
and part of it was because it was so
cheap there weren't any state taxes so
you could buy a carton of cigarettes for
seven dollars
so
we would usually have as we're running
in formation if somebody remembered to
bring it a pack of cigarettes and a
lighter in that pack of cigarettes and
the older guys had frown on this but we
younger guys would be like you know we'd
almost do like a relay you'd be running
a long Fast Pace take some Puffs on the
cigarette and then hand it up to the
next guy in front of you and then he'd
take it and puff on it or if he wasn't a
smoker he'd hand it to the next guy and
the cigarette would go you know like
halfway through the platoon before it
was consumed and then somebody light up
the next cigarette so we'd be running
and smoking at the the same time and we
could get away with that because we're
in such great shape looking back at it
it's kind of ridiculous but you know we
also would sometimes just go out for
runs for fun in the Army we also did
these folks marches because I was
stationed in southern Germany in Bavaria
Bayern and folks marches were kind of a
big deal
um and so you know those would usually
be like through the woods and there'd be
places where you could stop for beer and
stuff and since we were kind of Hardcore
we would sometimes we'd run in our
actual uniforms with like uh combat
boots and a backpack and you'd run
through the woods with all your buddies
sometimes we just put on some you know
some running gear and uh you know decent
running shoes and and uh run the the
course and then finish up and have some
beers and so that was the Army and then
you know I got out and uh started
working as a a cook again and you know
continuing exercise and running was was
a key part of that then I went to
college
and I went to college up in uh this
place called Lakeland at that time
college now Lakeland University
officially it's it's in Sheboygan but
it's actually like about 10 miles
outside of Sheboygan it's not even in
the village that it's it's uh viewed as
being closer to Howard's Grove it's it's
like on basically in the middle of corn
fields and and stuff and there was a guy
who uh I was studying in uh my Calculus
class with he was a local guy and he
liked running and and I liked running
he's like why don't we start running
together so so we do that and he was a
little bit older and he wasn't quite as
fast but you know he could keep up and
we'd run on these little roads around
and yeah that was a lot of fun
um to do that together and sometimes I'd
go running at night as well which could
be a little dicey because sometimes dogs
would you know chase you or stuff like
that but it was it was something that I
you know you feel certain vital quality
as you're doing it that's something I do
miss about being able to to run like
that even though I can still go for long
walks and you know I can do other things
where you got that feeling of movement
can't really run anymore unless I
absolutely have to and that's just for a
short pace and then I feel it in my my
knee afterwards
um so I continued running through
through college you know I uh helped
train the soccer team and you know of
course played some indoor soccer as well
that was a lot of fun that involved
running but Lakeland also had this
massive woods and Marsh that went all
the way to this river
behind the college it's all walled off
now you can't get back there
but I could go back there and run for
miles on these Trails some of them were
like well marked some of them were
basically just deer trails and I'll tell
you about something that happened that
was really quite cool I mean I would go
there and I'd run down to the river and
watch the carp rolling as their their
mating seeing the coppery scales or you
know see other kinds of Wildlife and it
was really quite wonderful but I was
running one time and I'm going fast
right and I've actually got like a stick
in my my hands because there were some
you know uh wild dogs that you'd have to
worry about and I come into a clearing
and at the same time running the
opposite direction
comes a stag and we are about
maybe six feet away from each other
just looking at each other both of us
stop and I can hear him snorting you
know and he's got like a full rack of
antlers and he's he's big you know and
but at that time I'm super athletic and
kind of charged up on my running and I
got this stick in my hands and I don't
know what the hell I thought I was gonna
do like you know somehow I'd
go after the deer or something like that
and so we're like standing there looking
at each other and he stamps his paw and
then he turns around and bolts the
opposite direction and I'm all charged
up on adrenaline and I chase after him
and he loses me within you know like a
minute or so because he knows the woods
way better and he's got four legs I've
got two and he is moving fast I don't
know what the hell I would have done I
would have caught up to that guy but it
was something pretty extraordinary
um then another really cool thing around
that time that happened I graduated from
college and
um
I was living in this little village that
was just down the road from Lakeland
called Franklin with Wild Bill and his
130 pound German Shepherd Lobo who was a
great dog loved the guy and Lobo really
liked me and uh Bill uh went away he
worked for like the park service or
something he had to go away for like a
month uh for trips and so I was just
working at this gas station convenience
store you know second shift and uh you
know reading and working out and stuff
like that and I decided I'd start taking
Lobo on runs and so we did that on these
County Roads you know we would get
together and maybe run over by Lakeland
or you know run other places and it was
a beautiful time of year it was like
July and August all these wonderful
flowers were in bloom there were places
we'd go where there were beehives you
could see the bees whizzing past you
from the field to their hives across the
road and man did Lobo love that and so
we had a great time together and then I
moved down to Milwaukee
and you know now once I was down in
Milwaukee I didn't really run so much
anymore I instead I was working two jobs
one is in in a as a barista in a cafe
the other is a third shift security
guard and I kept doing the taking walks
with the um
backpack full of Weights about 70 pounds
in there for conditioning and I would
listen to like you know
um tapes for learning languages at the
time in my my Walkman so I wasn't doing
a lot of running then and um I think it
just sort of like started to fall on the
Wayside for me
um after that year you know I went to
Europe for about uh five six weeks to
Quebec as well but I was traveling
around as a tourist with a big backpack
came back to here went immediately down
to Southern Illinois where I started
graduate school
and around that time I was about 25 or
so so we're talking about you know first
half of my current life uh and then um
you know I lived on campus the first
year and so I do a lot of walking not a
lot of running at that point anymore
um you know weightlifting doing other
kinds of exercise and then I moved into
a trailer park that was south of either
south or north of Campus maybe north of
Campus on 51 and it was about a mile and
a half I think to campus to the to the
edge of it and I would walk a lot and
then I got myself a bike and I would
just ride so I wasn't I wasn't running
for exercise I wasn't needing to it and
I would do it if I had to but it dropped
out of my
um
what would you call it my repertoire of
exercises because back then I was
actually working out two to three hours
a day
and uh at a certain point you know
because my legs are a bit messed up I
think you know the musculature and the
skeleton and you know my ankles it just
became
it wasn't painful to run for short
distances
but it became painful afterwards to run
you know for exercise and so I just I
was like well I guess I'll just do other
stuff instead and now it's decades later
um where I you know that that kind of
locomotive exercise going somewhere on
your feet with what we used to call your
leather personnel carriers your lpcs
back in the Army it's all done with
walking for me
um
and that's good enough but I think back
to those days the younger me and the
Delight
and vitality and enjoyment that was
there for me even as I'd get tired even
as it would be hot or you get sweaty or
you're stressing your body out I really
did enjoy it
um and so I thought I would you know I
was thinking about that the other day
and I thought I might share some of that
story with you
could be of interest to some and I would
encourage everybody is that wrap this up
you know you don't have to run but
everybody should be doing some exercise
because you don't want to I can say this
from experience you don't want to let
yourself get out of shape physically and
it's it's good also for your mind to be
exercising physically routinely so
that's all that I have to say about my
years and years and years of enjoying
running